hi there folks Chris waters here outside
the LA Convention Center where the video
game convention III is in 2/3 as mp3 is
in full Chouard citizens of the world
may we had a retention massive
communication you so dearly love as a
scam invite has been selling your data
to government agencies they've provided
clandestine access to information
security firms they will use your own
stolen information against you they will
attempt to change your behavior we are
looking at a single most powerful
population control tool ever created if
you are a building activist or someone
who simply wants to defend your freedom
of privacy join our cause as we
dismantle in fight we are dead sick join
us
which prompted many myself included to
hope I never see another tiny hamburger
again in my life it just goes to show
that the show is big and complex is III
anything is possible for more of the
latest news from e3 and expert analysis
on what it all means stay tuned to game
spot.com
I'm Chris waters signing off